Traducteur: eric vautier
Lucie Poumay :
Je suis sûre que depuis
les 30 dernières secondes
vous avez tous pensé à
au moins un vêtement
qui traînait inutilement
dans votre garde-robe.
Cette veste, par exemple, dont
les manches sont devenues trop courtes,
mais qui va tellement bien avec ce
pantalon que, finalement, vous la gardez.
Ou bien ce pull, dans lequel il y a un
trou, que, du coup, vous avez mis de côté
en vous promettant qu'un jour,
vous allez le réparer,
mais ça fait deux ans qu'il attend.
Vous vous reconnaissez ?
Moi aussi ! Et c'est normal.
Des histoires comme ça, on en a tous.
Marjorie Lambé :
Avoir une penderie avec 1 ou 2 pièces qui
traînent, ce n'est bien sûr pas un crime.
Cela dit, des nombreuses études avancent
des chiffes beaucoup plus interpellants,
comme, par exemple, 70% de notre
garde-robe ne serait pas portée.
Selon différents sources,
il y [aurait] aussi
[10], voire 20 kg de vêtements
qui seraient jetés,
chaque année, par personne,
et on en rachèterait une trentaine.
Ça ressemble un petit peu à du
gaspillage vestimentaire, non ?
Avoir une garde-robe bien remplie,
remplie à craquer,
c'est surtout un indicateur alarmant de
notre consommation excessive de vêtements,
qui engendre une production
excessive également.
Mais cette production est surtout un
problème au regard de l'énergie utilisée,
des pollutions qu'elle engendre,
et des droits de l'homme, de la femme
et de l'enfant constamment bafoués.
Savez-vous que, pour produire un jeans,
il faut environ
1 kg de coton,
et pour avoir ce kilogramme de coton,
il vous faut 5 à 25 000 litres d'eau,
2 kg d'encre chimique,
et 75 g de pesticide.
Et ici on parle uniquement du coton,
donc pas de transport, ni de lavage,
ennoblissement, teinture etc.
Donc c'est face à tous ces chiffres
que j'ai décidé de faire
quelque chose à mon échelle,
et j'ai ouvert une boutique de
seconde main, ici à Namur.
Car j'estime que la seconde main est un
moyen de réduire son empreinte écologique.
Et très peu de temps après
l'ouverture du magasin,
j'avais comme projet de m'associer
avec une styliste
pour montrer qu'il est possible
de s'habiller de manière très jolie
avec de vieux vêtements.
Et c'est à partir de ce moment-là
que Lucie est entrée en scène.
LP : Tout à fait !
En fait, l'idée de retravailler
des vêtements de seconde main
me trottait déjà en tête
depuis un petit moment.
En ayant fait des études en anthropologie
avant ma formation de stylisme,
les questions d'éthique et de durabilité
dans le secteur de la mode
se sont rapidement imposées à moi.
Quand on sait qu'on produit 57 millions de
tonnes de déchets textiles chaque année,
on peut se poser des questions.
Quand j'ai vu que
tu cherchais une styliste
pour un projet autour de la seconde main,
j'ai foncé directement sans trop savoir
dans quoi je me lançais, en fait.
Et, heureusement,
parce que si on m'avait dit
que j'allais devoir parler
devant 600 personnes
je crois que j'aurais
directement fait demi-tour.
(Rires)
Mais, à ce moment-là, tu savais
déjà qu'on allait participer au TEDx ?
ML : Non, non, non,
pas du tout, rassure-toi.
Mais c'était vraiment un projet que
j'avais à la boutique dès le depart.
Et, en fait, un ou deux mois
après l'ouverture,
quelques personnes du TEDX
sont venues me rendre visite,
pour me demander de faire un [talk].
J'ai tout de suite accepté.
Comme toi, je ne savais pas du tout
vers quoi j'allais.
Et peu du temps après que
tu as pris part au projet,
je le leur ai présenté
et elles m'ont dit que c'était super,
qu'elles étaient hyper ravies.
LP : Pour nous, ce soir,
c'est vraiment une super opportunité
de pouvoir vous présenter notre projet.
On tenait a préciser
qu'on est vraiment loin d'être les seules
à croire en ces alternatives.
Des projets dans le domaine
de la slow fashion, il en existe plein.
Que ce soit à l'international,
en Belgique,
et même à Namur, il en existe plusieurs.
ML : Et toi, avec tes études de stylisme,
as-tu peut-être des conseils
pour acheter de manière durable ?
LP : Tout à fait.
Pour le consommateur, on peut facilement
privilégier la qualité à la quantité.
Regarder où ont été
fabriqués nos vêtements,
se renseigner sur les marques
que l'on aime bien acheter,
ce sont quelques exemples
de choses que l'on peut faire.
Du côté des créateurs,
c'est un peu plus complexe.
Mais c'est, selon moi, là qu'est
le véritable enjeu pour le futur.
On peut par exemple designer
des vêtements qui produisent directement
beaucoup moins de déchets textiles.
On peut aussi privilégier l'utilisation
de ce qu'on appelle les indésirables.
Ce sont toutes ces choses qui aujourd'hui
terminent généralement à la poubelle.
Le défi, c'est de montrer qu'en fait,
ils ont énormément de potentiel.
Ce sont, par exemple,
les déchets issus la production.
Également les fins de stocks
des tissus industriels,
ou même des vêtements qui sont abimés.
Ce qu'on veut vraiment montrer,
c'est que, grâce à ces indésirables,
on peut en fait faire
des créations qui sont uniques,
et à un coût réduit.
C'est exactement ce qu'on a fait
pour notre collection « Récup »,
qu'on vous présente aujourd'hui.
ML : Cette collection tente
de revaloriser des vêtements
qui autrefois étaient abîmés ou
un peu trop difficiles à porter.
On a repris des pièces de la boutique
qui étaient donc invendables,
et on les a retravaillées à 100%.
Cette collection arbore quand même
des coupes simples, mais modernes.
Il y a du street wear, comme
des pièces un peu plus chics,
et masculin, féminin.
Et nous espérons que,
via cette collection,
vous serez convaincus que
la seconde main a beaucoup d'avenir,
beaucoup de potentiel,
beaucoup de possibilités.
LP : Alors on vous laisse en
compagnie de Nour, Canelle, Laurent,
Xavier, Julie et Amandine,
qui vont vous montrer
qu'on peut s'habiller
avec des vêtements qui
étaient destinés à la poubelle,
sans pour autant
LP & ML : avoir l'air d'un sac !
LP : Merci !
(Applaudissements)
(Chanson : « City Lights » - Sonnfjord)